при кліку франсуа фійона кандидата в
президенти вигляд консервативну квартири з
публікації полку скан дме що гвинт в ж
президент потім через так званий
зарплатний скандал become та фігура even
його дружина та двоє дітей рейтинг фійону
ризиків щодо
even за дружину фаворит перегоні политих
залишилося за клаптя ти зайнятий і свою
кандидатуру
all відому впливали один паркет ви
вирішив прикро тетяна в колонії ви про і
запускають вибрати у компанії фійоном
гвинтах та вугрі
франсуа фійон підтвердивши свою
кандидатуру на президентських виборах
політичний комітет республіканців
пісня обов'язку переговоривши 1 lost вона дала
йому свою питу премку багатий експертів
сумнівається в успіху ті та компанії
square джейд фійон ж куликова качка
витрати на до віру в барсі в його міг би
замінити екологічний приклад франсе all
ngp
ці пасив інше місце на папороть
виборах conservatory to die по парті
республіканці будуть шансон і прямо у
їхнього кандидата чи хтось електорату
мануеля макрону нестабільний теж оренду
п сама той хто нас проводиться краще
шанс конкурувати вата знаємо
моя дружина навколо icewm niva я хочу
франсуа фійон продовжити буду
кандидатами для республіканців краще
зачепін не вийду інший тур
президентських виборів
можливо пост ніби сівши пливу скандалу
то голосування лісу альянсу а натискай
фійона нині підлеглим тайському я до
політиці в таких граматику steam за
результатом і одного з досліджуваних
сімдесят дві сотні французьких вибір
цього дає винне зайняті свою
кандидатуру з виборів на довгі дачі
фійон околиш не міністр економіки
мануель macron у парижу ви породивши за
симпатії ми право по листку марин ле
пен у porsche матурі зама крона готували
дати своє волосся 27900 його плутаних залі
pn25 половину а за фійону вище 19